and then Ryan's called that Friday and
he said okay don't say anything just
listen US ambassador to the United
Nations I said Ryan I don't even know
what the United Nations does I just know
everybody hate this hey and welcome this
is the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special
and I am super excited to get to our
guest today my spirit animal former US
ambassador to the UN nikki Haley will
start that interview in just a second
but first it is spring the time of year
when seeds grow into flowers when you
grow up financially at least your family
needs protection if something happens to
you that means you need life insurance
thankfully policy genius makes it easy
to get that financial security without
the growing pains policy genius is the
easy way to buy life insurance online in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape no Commission's no hidden
fees just financial protection and peace
of mind no strings attached and policy
genius doesn't just simplify life
insurance they also make it easy to
compare and buy home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance so the
next time you stop to smell the roses
pull out your phone and head over to
policy genius.com policy genius spring
is here
kick it off by nipping life insurance in
the bud your responsible human make sure
that if something should happen to your
family is not left bereft and you are
not buried in a pauper's grave instead
go over to policy genius right now and
get the best life insurance policy money
can buy policy genius.com
be a good solid adult policy genius.com
go check it out right now ambassador
Haley thanks so much for coming on the
show really appreciate your time no this
is fun it's great to be here so let
start with us what you've been doing
since you left the Trump administration
I have enjoyed being a private citizen I
really have I think that people don't
realize that when you're in the UN you
really are only talking with Russia and
China and talking about issues you don't
really talk to normal people because you
can't trust talking to normal people you
have to keep everything close to the
chest and you have to you know focus on
that so it's nice to be out talking to
real people again and getting out there
talking about the things I care about so
doing that and then in the process of
writing a book
that book will come out in the fall and
that's gonna be it's really therapeutic
because that's you know me and during my
time as governor it's the transition
into the Trump administration it's the
UN what it was like the negotiations so
it'll be it's a lot of fun to write I'm
enjoying that and then we started a
policy platform because at the end of
the day I'm still a policy girl and
that's what I love and so we started
stand for America and it lets me talk
about all kinds of issues domestic
policy foreign policy we're really
trying to develop a grassroots
conservative group that one follows what
I'm doing but to talks about all the
good that's out there and all the
dangers that we need to be careful of so
between all of those things life is good
well I'm gonna ask you about your
political future in a while cuz I'd be
remiss if I didn't but I don't start
from beginning for folks who don't know
your history may have first saw you just
at the UN raising your hand sassily
the evil countries how did you get into
politics in the first place what sort of
your backstory well you know first I was
born in a small rural town in South
Carolina we were the only Indian family
we weren't white enough to be white we
weren't black enough to be black
my father wears the turban my mom at the
time wore sari no one knew who we were
what we were or why we were there and so
growing up like that I was always
different
I was always another and I remember
coming home after being bullied and my
mom would always say your job is not to
show how you're different your job is to
show how you're similar and it's
interesting because going through life
I've treated everything like that so the
same thing that happened as a
five-year-old on the playground is the
same thing I did when I was a governor
it's what I did as an ambassador is when
you have challenges it's a lot easier if
you will go through all the things you
agree on first and then go to the
challenge because it puts everybody's
guard down and all of a sudden lets them
relate to you a little bit more and so
those kinds of things really impacted
everything I did I started doing the
books for my parents business when I was
13 I did not know that wasn't normal
until I got to college
now I know it's child labor and I tell
them that all the time but it was there
that I learned the value of a dollar
you know when times were tough in our
small business I knew that we had to
hunker down we got creative
we got lean and we got smart and then
when times were good we never celebrated
because we knew it wouldn't last forever
and I carried that whole mindset to my
love of numbers and that's when I went
to Clemson go Tigers and graduated with
a degree in accounting went to corporate
America and worked there for a bit and
then I came back home to the family
business and it was there that again my
mom heard me saying how hard it was to
make a dollar and how easy it was for
government to take it and my mom said
quit complaining about it do something
about it I did not know you weren't
supposed to run against a 30 year
incumbent in a primary I really didn't I
was never that kid I was never in
college Republicans I was that was those
kids that wasn't me I didn't have any
political interest whatsoever but what I
did know is that there were way too many
lawyers in the State House and they
needed one good accountant and so we
campaigned once I it was a 30-year
incumbent so once I realized what I got
myself into the only option was to win
and so my husband drove the car my two
little ones were in the backseat and I
went door-to-door and just told everyone
that look I respected the 30-year
incumbent but I just wanted to do
something different and was elected and
that was kind of the start of the
political career how did your family
react when you said that you're running
for office your husband your kids how
did they react to that difficult life I
for a little I think there were three
and six at the time so they didn't
really know they would cheer on every
time they'd see like a 4x8 billboard
they'd be like mom and they Jeremy oh
they were my only cheering committee
because no one knew who I was so Michael
has always been unbelievably supportive
he's never said no he's never said don't
do it he's always said yeah you can do
this you should go ahead so and of
course my parents you know being
immigrants when you have
immigrants immigrant parents they're so
patriotic they're so grateful and my
parents literally there was not a day
that went by where my brothers my sister
and me didn't hear from my parents about
how blessed we were to be in this
country and how we had to remember that
and so that feeling they always
encouraged us to do anything my husband
was always supportive at everything and
then the kids I think just went along
for the ride so eventually you parlayed
that into becoming governor of South
Carolina and how did that job differ
from what you've been doing what
surprised you about the job of being
governor well you know being governor
with any job it is what you make it
right and so going into being governor
your number one job is to protect the
people of your state and then to grow
the state and what I wanted to do was
really change it I really South
Carolinians when I was campaigning
they're really hard on themselves they
were hard on our state they weren't very
complimentary of it and all I kept
thinking is how am I gonna sell
companies on this state if the people
themselves don't feel it and so it was I
think the business side of me and then
you know just the wanting to sell and
create jobs part of me that really put
me into high gear I knew that if you
could give someone a job you took care
of a family and I knew we had a lot of
families at that time to take care of I
think our unemployment was 11% plus and
so I literally as silly as it as went to
my assistant one morning and said can
you do me a favor and she said what and
I said the next person that calls and
this was all the public calls that would
come into the governor's office I said
the next person that calls answer the
phone it's a great day in South Carolina
how may I help you and she said really
and I said just try it I want to see how
this works and she did and the person
said well thank you it is a great day
and it's amazing when you put people's
guard down they all of a sudden you know
it there's just a kindness that comes
out and there's more of an ability to
bring the heat down a little bit and so
then I started saying it everywhere it's
a great day in South Carolina I'd start
every press conference
every speech every ribbon-cutting and by
the time we left not only did we have a
massive new Boeing plant we were making
more BMWs in that South Carolina plant
than any place in the world
we had Volvo we had mercedes-benz five
new international tire companies we were
number one in foreign exports and they
named us literally named South Caroline
the beasts of the southeast so which I
love the bottom line is when you're
governor you can really move the ball
you can change the culture you can
create the jobs you can go after the
budget and talk about the debt and
really kind of do direct things that
make that happen
obviously when challenges happen you
have to hunker down and and protect the
people of your state but it was a job I
loved I mean I was blessed to serve the
state that raised me I really was so how
did you deal with the the slings and
arrows that come along with with being
in politics so I obviously get some but
you've gotten a lot more of it because
your career is longer and you're an
elected official I remember back when
you were campaigning for governor and
people were putting out scurrilous
rumors about you on a near daily basis
how did you grow a skin thick enough to
deal with that just as a human being I'm
very disciplined when it comes to that
politics is the art of distraction and
you can't get distracted and you know so
when you get distracted your opponents
win and so that would only make me hone
anymore it would only make me more
disciplined and I just really at the end
of the day think people are good and
they can see through things and if
you're genuine and good to them they
will be genuine and good back they've
proven that to me so many times through
so many different scenarios and so I
think it look it's hard not to take it
personally it happens but you have to
because the second you start taking it
personally they win and that just made
me more determined that once I got to
the position I had to make it mean
something because I mean there were a
lot of bruises from me there bruises
from every campaign there's bruises in
public life people are ruthless
you know from what you wear to how you
look to what you say to you know your
family everything else and so you really
have to make
that if you're gonna go into public life
it has to mean something
so as governor of South Carolina I think
the first time that a lot of people saw
you on the national stage was the
controversy with regards to the removal
of the Confederate battle flag from the
from the war monument that was outside
the State Capitol building I believe so
maybe you can take us through your
thinking on that it emerged the whole
controversy emerged in the aftermath of
the horrible terrorist attack on the on
the historically black church in South
Carolina they didn't take us through the
logical next I know that that raised a
lot of ire on both sides and and
obviously you had to take a tough
position it was painful it was
absolutely painful here was on a
Wednesday night 12 people did what a lot
of people in South Carolina did they
went to Bible study mother Emanuel is
one of the oldest African American
churches it's a beautiful church and
people typically families for
generations go to that church and but on
that night someone else showed up and he
didn't look like them he didn't sound
like them he didn't act like them but
they didn't kick him out they didn't
call the police they pulled up a chair
and they prayed with him for an hour and
in that last prayer when they bowed
their heads he started to shoot now what
made this so devastating was the
goodness of these people you had someone
like Ethel Lance she had lost her
daughter two years prior to breast
cancer and was just brokenhearted but
she would go around mother Emmanuel and
clean and she would sing a song that was
one day at a time sweet Jesus that's all
I ask of you give me the strength to do
every day what I have to do you had the
youngest victim tywanza sanders I mean
contagious smile a life in front of him
he had just graduated college and on
that night he stood in front of his 93
year old aunt Susie and said you don't
have to do this we mean no harm to you
or you had someone like cynthia hurd
whose life motto was to be kinder than
necessary that's who these people were
these were people who lived their life
every day just trying to be good they
took care of their families they had
jobs they went to church it was what
every South Carolinian did and the pain
of that and the fact that it was in the
most sacred of places that was the part
I couldn't get my heart around was when
you go to a place of worship
that's your with God that's like that
that's your close to closest feeling to
God and you feel the safest and you feel
like you can let your guard down and
you're your most vulnerable and the idea
that someone could do this in a church
was just pure hate and I remember going
to my law enforcement director and I
said chief please tell me he had a
mental illness I so wanted him to say
that and he said he didn't so once we
knew it was hate I knew that I had to
protect the state but my bigger problem
was I had to keep the national media out
they so wanted in on this they wanted to
define it they wanted to talk about it
in their terms they wanted to talk about
the solutions and I literally had to
just push them off and say stop we're
gonna have these funerals we're gonna
give the respect to these families and
during that time it was a presidential
primary so all the candidates wanted to
weigh in on it so I was on the phone
with the candidates telling them to stay
out but the beautiful part was that next
day when the killer presented himself
for the first time in front of the judge
those families unscripted unrehearsed
not having talked to each other
walked up looked the killer in the eye
and forgave him I mean that kind of
forgiveness through their pain they
forgave him and prayed for him and
there's so many lessons that can be
learned through that and the people of
South Carolina they didn't
test they had vigils they didn't have
riots
they had hugs and so from that
standpoint it was a healing time the
problem was that the killer did a
manifesto and the very picture on the
manifesto was him standing there with a
confederate flag so now the Confederate
flag in South Carolina by many was
viewed as heritage service family
history there was a real traditional
component to it and then the others who
know it as you know what people remember
in slavery and all those things so you
had this one group of people that saw it
as a part of them saw it as a part of
their tradition but literally after I
saw that image and that image went all
over the world I knew that something had
to be done and so that next day we
announced that we were going to bring
the flag down it was a tough debate what
made it hard as we had to have 2/3 vote
in both the House and the Senate and you
know it was just a matter of I think
there was a little bit of you know just
communication a lot of Prayer and just
believing in the people in South
Carolina and so yes it was a tough
debate what I made sure I communicated
was a flag as a living breathing
representative symbol a monument is very
different a monument represents a moment
in history a past moment in time so I
made it very clear to my state that look
the flag needs to come down because I
don't want a single child to look at
that flag and feel pain or see the
killer's face or any of that but we're
not going to start taking down monuments
because those are monuments we learn
from that's how we make sure we never
forget so what we did on the monument
side was an african-american museum went
up a mine
to the mother Emanuel in tribute went up
that's how that needs to be handled if
you take down a monument you're not
erasing history you're just taking
something down thinking you proved a
point when you didn't you just erased a
lesson so in a second I want to ask you
about a little more about the
Confederate flag and then I want to talk
about the accusations of racism against
the Republican Party more generally but
first why are you not a daily wire
subscriber I know you think that you're
saving yourself money by not being a
daily wire subscriber but here's the
reality you're missing out on life
because the fact is that for $9.99 a
month not only do you get access to
Sundays specials like this one on
Saturday not only do you get access to
the final question of the Sunday special
they wouldn't otherwise get you also get
access to additional two hours of me
every single day you get my podcast the
full video of the podcasts live and then
you get all of it on demand and you get
two additional hours of me every day
that I do in the afternoon so if you
just can't get enough of me then I mean
you got to go check us out over at daily
wire plus we have a website that brings
you the best in news we have the Andrew
Clavin show and the Matt Walsh show and
God knows why you might want the Michael
Moore's show for some odd reason you get
all that and when you get the annual
subscription you also get one of these
right get the leftist ears hot or cold
tumblr and as you all know this will
infuse you with both brilliance as well
as physical health none of that is
guaranteed but I can guarantee you that
your life will be better if you
subscribe over at daily wire.com so go
check us out for $9.99 a month or 99
bucks a year okay so I want to ask you
about the the competitor flag one moment
more so as you mentioned for a lot of
folks in the South who have confederate
flags on their truck this does not
represent slavery it doesn't represent
um crow it represents my dad fought
under that flag in the Battle of the
Bulge this represents southern heritage
and as you rightly point out also for
black folks for many black folks in the
United States I'm sure a vast majority
black folks in the United States they
look at that flag and they rightly see a
symbol that was flying flying over the
soldiers that were keeping people
enslaved so do you feel at all that that
in your decision and the decision of
legislature to take down the flag there
was danger in taking one side of that
debate in saying okay well so evil human
being associated this with the worst
parts of the heritage of this flag and
by taking it down it was saying well
that's correct that this that's really
what the flag represents and
I remember a lot of the blowback around
the time was sort of centered on that
yeah look he defined it if anybody wants
to be angry be angry at the killer
because he's the one that gave the
modern-day version of what he wanted the
Confederate flag to be any time you're
in a trying situation anytime things are
hard you have to take a side you have to
take a side because the worst thing you
can do for the people you serve is take
no side or play both sides a decision
had to be made and this was one where I
couldn't look my kids in the eye if I
didn't do this every child that drove by
all the third graders that would come to
the Statehouse every year I didn't want
them to see that because I knew the
history of the killer and what he did
would last forever I didn't do that the
killer did that and so we when we
brought the Confederate flag down we
didn't do pomp and circumstance it was
very respectful it was done granted
thousands of people showed up I knew it
was bad when I looked over in the
Weather Channel van was there like
everybody had come in on South Carolina
but we had it respectfully taken down
respectfully held respectfully
transported to the museum so that it can
be in its proper place and so I was
trying to be respectful to both sides
but I had to take aside so one comes to
accusations of racism inside the
Republican Party a lot of folks have
used the fact that there was debate over
the flag a lot of people sided against
you in that debate as evidence that the
Republican Party is more broadly racist
and that's also been a charge that's
been leveraged just against Republicans
for a very long time Joe Biden who
obviously is now the Democratic
frontrunner in 2012 suggesting that Mitt
Romney wanted to put y'all back in
Chains with regard to to black folks
constant accusations that President
Trump is racist and we'll get to
President Trump in a little while what
do you make of the general accusation
that the Republican Party is either
making room for racism or is embodying
racism itself well I mean look we all
have a responsibility when it comes to
racism and you know I've felt it I know
other people have felt it that kind of
pain is a really deep-seated pain it's
one that really hurts you at your core
because you can't change who you are
you can't change those facts and you
don't want to change those facts so
racism will always be there
unfortunately but how we choose to
respond to it is really important
because mine was one give people the
benefit of doubt people don't mean to be
racist some are older some grew up in a
different generation and they think
differently if you look at my children
they don't see race at all it's
completely different and so I do always
try and take into account the
generations and those that are dealing
with it but at the same time respect for
different races applies to everyone
Republicans and Democrats when I was
running for governor I had a Republican
a white Republican that called me a rag
head I had a black Democrat say that I
wasn't a minority I was just a
conservative with a tan racism comes
from both sides and so I think we have
to be honest and you know look the
Republican Party you see a lot of white
men so I think that doesn't help the
scenario but look at the actions of the
Republican Party I wouldn't be there if
I didn't believe in the fact that I am a
conservative I do think that government
does not need to control all things and
we we need to appreciate our freedoms we
need to see the opportunities we need to
allow them to grow we need to let every
person feel what it's like to be in
America and not infringe on that I've
seen what happens in other countries we
are blessed to be in this country and we
have to remember to be grateful and I I
think when it comes to the racism I
didn't just have to worry about what
white pro-confederate flag people cared
about I had to sit down and have
breakfast with Jesse Jackson every other
day to keep him at bay I had to talk to
Al Sharpton's they do not bring that
hate speech in the south
Linna it goes both ways and so if we
really are gonna deal with the issue of
racism you have to call it out for what
it is to everyone I mean to me racism
was being at the UN and seeing what they
were doing to Israel you know I called
them out and I think we should always
call it out when it happens but try and
move past it try and do something that
makes them think it's harder it takes
longer but that's how you change a
culture this brings us all the way up to
2016 during the 2016 race
you were vocally against President Trump
in the in the primaries and then you
endorsed him for the general I believe
but maybe can take us through your throb
thought process along the the 2016
spectrum because there's a lot of
movement for a lot of folks along that
line I think people don't realize I knew
President Trump for a few years he
actually endorsed me my first governors
race I remember getting this great
envelope like had gold trim the whole
thing and he had sent a check and so I
called him and then after that we had
met you know throughout the years if I
was in New York or and we'd talk on the
phone so we were cordial this was the
fact that we had a lot of people on that
stage a lot of talent on that stage and
I was giddy at how many great candidates
we had and so trying to pick the one
that fit was hard but I actually didn't
know Marco very well but once I've met
him we had so much in common
growing up wanting to really deal with
the racial side of how people see that
there were just a lot of things that we
connected on and so he felt like the
right candidate for me he was younger I
wanted somebody younger I mean there
were a lot of different reasons having
said that once the president won the
primary I was with him you know that I
knew we needed a Republican in the White
House and we had all felt eight years of
what President Obama was and we had all
suffered from it businesses suffered
people suffered you know foreign policy
suffered and so you know once the
president got in I got the
call from Ryan saying that you know he
wants to talk to you and I said about
what and he said
Secretary of State and I said science
I'm a governor I can't be Secretary of
State and he said well he wants to meet
with you so the next day I went to New
York I met with him and I just from the
beginning said I'm not your person you
know I think that we're at a point in
time in foreign policy where we don't
need a learning curve we need to make
sure that we have the right person but I
will support and help in any way that I
can to help you find someone and then I
went back to a job I loved and then
riots called that Friday and he said
okay don't say anything just listen US
ambassador to the United Nations I said
Ryan I don't even know what the United
Nations does I just know everybody hates
it and he said just think about it over
the weekend
and that's when my husband Michael he
was on the computer that night it's like
they can't think you'd be really good at
this and it was a tough time look I had
a you know I had a daughter in college
she was a freshman in college
Nayland my son was 15 and you know it's
a time you don't want to move your kids
I take care of my parents they both live
with us Michael and I have taken care of
them for eight years they're both in
their 80s my mom has Parkinson's and so
it you know it was just I have a
military combat veteran husband who you
know is coming and going so it just
wasn't the right time to make a move and
then the president called on that Monday
and he said all right Nick are you gonna
do this and I said I just things would
have to be you know right to do this and
he said like what and I saw I've been a
governor so I don't want to go work for
someone I wouldn't want to work with you
this would need to be a cabinet position
he said done he said what else I said
well I'm a policy girl and I said so I
want to be in the room when policy is
made and I'd have to be on the National
Security Council
he said done what else that was the
moment right that's like oh no and then
I said well I'm not gonna be a
Wallflower talking-head
I need to be able to say what I think
and he said that's exactly why I want
you to do this and
it took off from there and he was true
to his word every step of the way
so what is your after having served with
you and what's your overall view of UN
so I have been vocally anti UN for as
long as I can possibly remember I've
recommended that the building be torn
down the president Trump build condos on
top of it you've served there what is
that do you think there is a purpose to
the UN do you think it's a useful
organization what should the u.s. is
involvement in the UN be the president
actually asked me a year-end said what
do you think of the UN should we stay in
and I said this is a thing it's wasteful
its bureaucratic it's a lot of talk and
not as much action there's resentment
we're being taken advantage of but we
would not have gotten those three North
Korean sanctions packages and had the
international community all on the same
page against North Korea without the UN
so I think the American people are going
to decide I don't know that I've decided
yet but the UN has it has to really we
pushed some really big reforms in the
first year we were able to cut 1.3
billion immediately that was just
low-hanging fruit when people see the
big UN building they think ambassadors
are in there that's just staff you have
thousands of people that work in that
building and it's all because countries
want their people in there the staff has
doubled in the last 10 years
that's how ridiculous it is the reforms
were happening we did work with the
secretary-general it was starting but
it's got a long way to go and the UN
more importantly has to change with the
times they can't keep talking about old
issues they've always wanted to talk
about they have to take on issues like
Venezuela which they didn't want to do
they have to take on those issues with
Iran and call it out the way it is in
any way for them to continue to be
relevant they have to do what's
uncomfortable to do and I don't know if
they're willing to do that yeah I mean
that's been my main criticism of the UN
is you look at the Human Rights Council
that's filled with human rights
violators you look at the women's rights
council it's filled with women's rights
violators you look at the UN Security
Council and you have countries that are
you know deeply and I have deep
antipathy for the United States trying
to dick
policy to the United States while we
flip the bill and I just wonder wouldn't
we better be better off working with the
Alliance's that we've already forged
working with NATO creating a new league
of democracies doing something like that
and I think it may come to that because
I mean when you look yes were we able to
move the ball we were but it is what you
make it but for all the heat we took and
the resentment and the part that
bothered me I always tried to show value
to the citizens because they were paying
for it but the part that bothers me is
we pay so much money China doesn't pay
much because they're considered a
developing country they're not a
developing country we only have five
vetoes which can stop anything it's the
permanent members it's the UK France US
China and Russia they can stop anything
the Russian veto was one of the hardest
parts about my job they pay less than 6%
we pay 22% of operating now it was 28
now it's 25% of peacekeeping that's an
enormous amount and they're getting that
veto right for very little so it's not
fair it's not a fair scenario we made it
very clear something was going to have
to give I still think we need to hold
them to that standard if they don't make
the changes we should strongly look at
the fact are we getting this now Beijing
would love to have it fine
if Beijing wants to have it let them
have it if they're not gonna start to
really I don't want us to give more than
25 percent the UN shouldn't want us to
give more than 25 percent it's not
healthy for any organization so it has
to change with the times and right now
it's choosing to be archaic and stuck
let's talk a little bit about your
generalized view of foreign policy so
there's this hot debate on the right
particularly that ranges from sort of an
isolationist view on the right that we
shouldn't be involved in any activity
around the world people for example
saying that we should basically leave
Maduro in power without even trying to
exert influence because that's American
imperialism and where has that worked
before and then there folks who are
extraordinarily interventionist you
believe that we should be involved
nearly everywhere where do you come down
that debate what how would you define
what you think the ideal American role
in the world would be I define it now
about what I saw with all the other
countries at the UN
after a side did the chemical weapons
strike and the president said we're
going to enforce the redline and he did
the strikes against in Syria
the number of countries that came and
spoke to me texted me or pulled me aside
and said it's so good to see the United
States lead again was overwhelming now
they're not gonna say it publicly but at
the end of the day they may resent us
they may not like us but they see us as
the moral authority they do want a
country to follow and I think that the
u.s. always needs to be a leader but we
need to be a leader in values we need to
be a leader in smart foreign policy we
need to be a leader in calling things
out for what they are and so values if
you look at who we kind of consider our
threats right now China Russia Iran
Venezuela Syria they don't agree with
our values either it doesn't work so
from that standpoint I think we should
always keep that in mind the second idea
is we shouldn't be quick to go to war no
Americans want to go to war that should
always be a last resort and understand
there is a middle ground the reason we
pushed for the North Korean sanctions
they were I mean the threat was very
real not just to the peninsula to to
many countries and the reason we did the
sanctions was because every ounce of
money that was going into North Korea
they weren't feeding their people they
were building their nuclear war chest so
through the sanctions we cut off 90% of
their trade 30% of their oil all of
their exports and we just starved it to
the point that they came to the table
you know HR McMaster at the NSC he went
had diplomats other countries expel
their diplomats or closed their
embassies so they felt very isolated
I think pressure goes a long way and
getting other countries with you goes a
long way so I you know I think people
always say there one way or the other
I think if you're gonna be smart you
have to one keep your values in check to
always
be willing to exert pressure but three
think about the long game where is it
that you want to go what is it that
you're trying to accomplish and and go
from there so I think it's dangerous
when you start to label foreign policy
President Obama and every president has
the ability to decide what they want
their foreign policy to be he decided he
just didn't want to rock the boat he
didn't want to be involved he wanted us
that he wanted all other countries to
like us and he wanted to focus
domestically well the United States paid
the price for that you know when when
the Trump administration came in and
when I came in we had chemical weapons
being used in Syria we had massive
protests in Venezuela we had Iran who
had just gotten literally a Plane full
of money and instead of just being
causing problems in their circle they
were now involved in Yemen in Lebanon in
Afghanistan in Syria in Iraq I mean they
had really put their tentacles out
because we just gave them the money to
do that you know all in the name of
trying to work with them we had North
Korea that was threatening every day I
mean we were gonna mess and so the best
way to fix that is to have a strong
voice and my way of using it at the UN
was I wanted every country to know what
we were for and what we were against and
that there were no gray lines and it
allowed other countries to follow and
while they may not like our decision
they'd like it when we make decisions
when we move there's been a lot of talk
about the front doctrine it is there
Trump doctrine it seems like because the
administration has historically been
pretty leaky you get various characters
who are complaining the president
obvious has gone through a couple of
secretaries of state at this point
there's been some turnover if you had to
define what the Trump doctrine is on
foreign policy is there a way to define
that down I think it was you know being
assertive taking a stand and following
through those were the main things what
you have in the in the administration is
personalities the personalities aren't
necessarily the decisions he makes and I
think we've seen that play out you know
obviously there were a lot of
personalities on the NSC that didn't
want him to move the embassy to
Jerusalem he
anyway you know there were a few people
who didn't want him to do the strikes in
Syria he did it anyway
so while he listens to all of those I
think he's more about being assertive
and making sure that countries
understand that when you say something
don't test us because we'll follow
through with it
so you served in the administration
obviously how would you rate president
Trump's presidency on a scale of one to
ten I think it depends so foreign policy
I think he's been quite strong and I
think that our standing in the world the
respect has come up the strength that
we've shown and the ability to falter
was strong domestically I think there
have been some really big wins the tax
cuts were huge it's the first time
Americans felt some hope there was some
extra cash in their pocket I saw with
the people that worked in our office and
those government employees so many of
them work paycheck to paycheck just
suddenly see not just a little bump but
a big bump in their paycheck was huge I
think the idea that the foreign aid side
which was something that I've felt very
strongly about is that we yes we are a
generous country we're always gonna care
about humanitarian issues we're always
gonna deliver on that but we are no
longer gonna give countries money in the
name of them liking us you know I think
from the budget I'm disappointed I think
that the dead is way too high I think
that we have to start looking at fiscal
discipline but you know you have your
priorities and it falls down there and
unfortunately at that point I think
that's a little bit down but I think the
president has really brought a voice
that was needed there's times in a
country and we're seeing this not just
in the US we're seeing it all over where
the people didn't feel heard and he made
them feel like the power of their voice
mattered and I still think you know
obviously we have a long way to go on
bureaucracy and obviously we have a long
way to go on some other things but the
way the foreign policy is working the
domestic side it's so politically toxic
right now that I'm frustrated with both
Republicans and Democrats you
at the end of the day we have to get
something done and I think what bothered
me the most was the shutdown Congress
knew Republicans and Democrats knew that
if they didn't get it right government
was going to shut down they have one job
one job and when they shut down
government I was so angry because they
left with their paychecks they were
getting paid these public servants that
work in government them going paycheck
to paycheck they thought it was okay to
say oh you'll get it when government
opens back up which was like six eight
weeks later how are they going to pay
rent you want to talk about payday loans
you want to talk that's what leads into
that so the thought of that average
worker went right out the window when I
was governor I would always put both
sides in the room and say we're not
leaving until we figure this out
Congress never should have left they
never should have gotten paid when
government was shut down and they should
have thought more about the American
people and I think that the people need
to remind them they have a job to do
immigration if that's such a big issue
do something about it get in a room and
do something why are we not debating
that right now u.s. MCA the trade deal I
mean Mexico and Canada aren't gonna pass
it until they see the u.s. pass it why
aren't we voting on that there's a lot
of things that just aren't moving that
need to be done all the ambassadors that
we don't have out around the world what
does that say about the United States
they don't care that Republicans and
Democrats can't get it right but our
standing in those countries is weakened
so there's just I think I wish they all
would work together more in the name of
the American people and not be so
politically toxic and I think we've
gotten to a place where it's really
important I mean it's it's so bad that
when you have a good piece of
legislation that someone puts down
everybody wants to know whose it is
first before they decide if they like it
that's when you know you've hit rock
bottom when we given Democratic
intransigence what options do you think
President Trump has I mean especially on
immigration for example which you
made a staple of his campaign in 2016
and moving forward into 2020 what
recommendations would you give to the
president given that the Democrats won't
even give him the funding necessary to
provide beds for the people who are
crossing the border illegally I think
the president's making a strong argument
that is real remember his number-one job
is to protect the people of this country
and my parents came here legally they
put in the time they put in the price
they they had to work to get here they
are offended by anyone that comes here
illegally and that's the thing is if you
talk to legal immigrants they sacrifice
to be here for the benefits of being
here if you don't follow the rules to
get here why would you follow the laws
when you're here and that's the part
that they have to understand America
immigrants are the fabric of America
it's what makes us great it's we need as
many immigrants as we can we need the
skills we need the talent we need the
culture we need all of that but we're a
country of laws and the second you give
up being a country of laws you've lost
everything this country was founded on
and so if you don't like something
that's happening fix it we can't have a
hundred thousand people last month on
the us-mexico border and then sit there
and say do we let them go do we not let
it go where do we keep I mean it's a
debate that really needs to stop all
we're talking about is processes all
we're talking about is the fact that we
need to know who's here where they're
from and have we done the background
check and I think when it comes to
asylum seekers and this is a good
example from South Carolina in South
Carolina we thought we were part of a
federal refugee program like many states
in the country and that's where you take
the persecuted that's where you take
those that are in fear of their life in
other countries but my husband was
deployed to Afghanistan for a year
his unit when they came home the first
thing they cared about were those two
interpreters that kept them safe all
year and they knew that if they stayed
they would die that refugee program
allowed them to go to the process come
here they're now both working had their
families contributing back it can work
if you remember all this debate started
with the Syrian refugees a few years ago
and I remember as governor calling the
FBI director then James Comey and saying
tell me how are the Syrian refugees any
different than what we have here
he said we literally have no information
on them he said I have no background I
have no family
I had no history nothing what that point
I said South Carolina is not going to
participate in this because you can't
allow people to come in that you don't
know anything about them and so that's
what this is this asylum seekers it's
not that we don't feel for them it's not
that we don't hurt for them I can
actually tell you the u.s. combined with
the UN the u.s. lead with the UN we had
teams along the caravan borders to give
health care and safety because we were
worried about the lives of those people
we were worried about trafficking we
were worried about many of them were
getting sick so you know it's not that
we don't care it's the fact that we have
to protect American citizens first and
then go through the processes of doing
that for anyone that doesn't want the
immigration rules to come into play how
else do we protect the country that's
our job that's that's what we have to do
and so literally this is one of those
Congress get in a room figure it out I
think the president's done all he could
possibly do he's pointed out the facts
he said it's a crisis he's literally
given it to them and we need Republicans
and Democrats to say time to get to work
I mean at some point the president can
only do so much this is a congressional
thing and I think that we have to put a
lot of weight on that and put the
pressure on them he's he can talk about
it he can bring the issues up he can do
what few executive orders he can do but
at the end of the day the American
people have to put the pressure on
Congress to say this is a priority for
us it may not be for you but it is for
us all right so I want to ask you about
the increasing radicalism that seems to
be cropping up in the Democratic Party
the intersectionality driven philosophy
of the Democratic Party making
for anti-semitism in my opinion the
Democratic Party going out of its way
not to condemn the overt anti-semitism
of both receded to leave as well as
Ilhan Omar people rallying around Oh
Hannah Maher and suggesting that she's
somehow a victim when people quote her
what do you make of the Democratic
Party's move toward toward the radical
left and do you see them moving toward
moderation anytime soon I think first we
have to say something very clear
anti-semites or racists right and so
when you see anti-semitism that's a
racial problem now again look at the
parties if it was any other group you
would be incredibly upset so it's a very
odd thing for me to see that the
Democrats are not stepping up on this
you know when they passed when Congress
passed that resolution that was nothing
they literally did name Omar they didn't
do anything it was the most watered-down
week res a a piece of legislation I had
seen why even do it
the thing is call people out you've got
a serious problem when people are saying
things that are that hurtful and that
devices and just to let you know the
killer of the Charleston shooting it all
started with the Trayvon Martin case
that's when it got in his head that's
when he started to hear things that's
when he started to hear the
back-and-forth and then he went online
and he did that words matter words
matter and so I think from that
standpoint there is no place in our
country for any racist language
whatsoever now at the same time we have
to be responsible with that right you
have to make sure that you're in check
and you're not being overly sensitive
but I think we have to be careful with
that from the the extremism that we're
seeing it's really fascinating because
if you look at the Republican primary
last time we had a lot of talent on that
stage and what happened the media didn't
pick up your average joes they went
further and further to the right and it
was all about the
soundbites it was all about the most
radical things that were said now you
flip it we've got a Democratic primary
what they perceive as a lot of talent on
their stage and it's going further and
further to the left you've got great New
Deal you've got anti-semitism you've got
socialism you've got all these things
and what's the media talking about the
furthest to the left you have a hundred
and four new congressional members they
only talk about three so the media has
now taken on the sound bites the
Democrats have really taken on sound
bites okay if socialism works they throw
out how happy everybody would be but no
one asked the extra question well why is
Venezuela like that well what happens my
friend had to get surgery and knee
surgery in Canada she ended up coming to
Washington State to get it done because
she would have to wait eight months or
she could afford to do that what does
that say for those people that can't
afford it is socialism good for them and
so I think that you know when Bernie
says you know health care for all and
and and Elizabeth is saying Oh free
college tuition for all it's dangerous
because you're talking in sound bytes
and you're not actually saying oh but do
you know what debt we're going to put on
the country do you know what we're gonna
have to sacrifice for that I mean
there's no long thought coming out of
this Democratic primary so far they have
to explain the solution not the
soundbite and that's happening but I
think there's something that's even
worse and that is that what we've seen
through these last couple of years is
the political toxicity has reached a new
level and we've seen where parties are
referring to the others as evil and the
hate and the rhetoric has gone up that
bothers me because I've seen evil I've
been to the Democratic Republic of Congo
where they used rape as a form of war
I've been Miss Al Sudan and sat with the
women who have told stories of
the military coming in grabbing their
babies from their arms and throwing them
in fires I've been to Venezuela on the
Simon Boulevard bridge where those
families are walking hours in the Sun
holding their babies for the one meal
they may get that day the average
Venezuelan adult has lost 24 pounds I've
seen the pictures of kids who have died
from chemical weapons in Syria that's
evil we're just having differing
opinions so at some point the hate level
has to come down and a serious debate
needs to happen there's a lot of issues
we need to debate whether it's
immigration whether it's socialism
whether it's the you know green New Deal
whether its term limits that I strongly
believe in we need to have those debates
but we don't need to hate each other
through the process and so and I think
that's actually keeping us from being
productive while everybody's busy hating
each other other countries are
succeeding other countries are doing
really well and they're all looking at
us wondering what's going on so I think
we have to get our country in check I
think we have forgotten to be grateful I
mean on our worst day we are blessed to
be in America and it won't always stay
that way we have a responsibility to
keep it that way and political
infighting or partisan fighting isn't
gonna fix it
it's gonna stall any progress from going
forward when we talk about the divisive
nests inside the Democratic Party the
increasing radicalism of the Democratic
Party the intersectionality the the
support for folks like Allen Omar for
whom folks are continuing to raise money
the immediate response from media when
any of this is mentioned is of course
President Trump the suggestion is that
his language is is not in keeping with
sort of the the tenor and tone that
you're using and Joe Biden launched his
campaign for the presidency this year
with a reference to Charlottesville
which you know I thought was a real low
point for the president what did you
make of Charlottesville what do you make
of president Trump's impact on the
rhetorical divides and racial divides in
the country when Charlottesville was
happening I picked up the phone
and called the president and I had a
private conversation about what I
thought he was saying what I thought it
meant and my opinion on that and so I'm
gonna keep I think those private
conversations need to stay private
everyone has a responsibility with their
language and their tone including the
president and so I think that when
you've seen tragedies and places of
worship like we are continuing to see I
think when you're seeing school
shootings I think when you these are the
things that can happen if you don't
watch your tone people get hurt people
die and so there is a responsibility
anytime you are in public office anytime
the true a public person there is a
responsibility and what you say and how
you say it and to make sure that it
can't be perceived by anything I saw
what that killer saw in the Trayvon
Martin case
and he kept hearing the rhetoric from
both sides and it made him angry the
things he said to them in that church
that day were all about what he had
heard that black people did and why they
were harmful to white people these
things matter and look I mean is there a
quick fix to say tomorrow we're all
gonna be better no are we always gonna
have division yes but at some point you
have to look in the mirror and say what
am i doing about it how do we draw that
line no I mean in terms of using harsh
language in where do you draw the line
between robust political debate and
quote unquote incitement because you've
seen that happen also as people suggest
that incitement is happening simply
because somebody disagrees on an issue
so omar has suggested that president
from quoting her for example is
incitement of violence against her how
do we how do we draw that line so the
way I've always looked at it I think
this is always you know every person is
their own judge is I believe you always
speak truth give the facts give your
opinion but don't ever let it be
personal I mean that's the part when you
start to and you can always tell these
decisions when they start to get
personal that's when you have to stop
and if you say something that is
offensive doesn't mean you should
apologize you know doesn't mean because
if you meant it and you feel it but
understand that when you say something
some won't take it that way and decide
whether you're comfortable with that the
problem with Omar that I have is where
is the Democratic Party like at what
point yes we can be offended by what she
says it is very telling how silent they
are about what she says that's the part
that should bother everyone in this
country because if race matters that
much if anti-semitism and violence and
what can happen matters that much why
aren't we calling them out where are
they saying things
why is everyone giving them a pass and
you know again so I would call them out
on that but I don't think you have to
talk about someone's hair the way they
look or you know call them evil or
anything like that I think that's when
you're getting too far it's be
professional about it be passionate
about it have fun with it but don't lose
yourself in that and don't cut someone
else without everybody has a family and
everybody has their own challenges and
everybody has their own strengths and
their own Falls remember these are real
people but you can disagree and I think
the debate should always be healthy and
passionate I just think it should never
get personal so a lot of folks are
looking forward to 2024 and thinking of
you as a prospective candidate do you
have any interest in running for the
presidency come 2024 what are you
looking at I have been blessed to serve
the state that raised me and more
blessed to serve the country I love so
much I am too young to stop fighting I
know that it is the reason why I have
started stand for America so go to wwm
for america.com and and follow us is to
have that voice and be that person that
continues to to talk about where I think
we're going right and where I think
we're going wrong as a country
but my husband and I have never talked
about anything in public office going
further so I say that to you in that if
it was something we were thinking about
we would have had that conversation it's
not anything that we've thought about I
really am enjoying just coming down a
notch the stress level coming down
spending time with Rena and Nalin and
Michael and and kind of doing things we
hadn't done before and I just want to do
that but I it's in my blood I don't know
how not to say something when I see
something wrong I don't know how not to
care about moving the ball in this
country I just have to see where that
takes me
looking at the radical polarization in
the country are you optimistic or
pessimistic about where the country is
headed at this point I'm optimistic
because I know the capabilities of this
country I'm optimistic because I know
the goodness of people it's hard to see
the light right now but I know the
people are good I know the values I know
everything about where we want to go as
a country is good it's a culture that
we've taken on that's bad and so we just
have to go back to changing that culture
and again it's gonna take leaders who
see culture is important it's gonna take
people who believe values matter and
that they have to stay true to those and
I think that it's going to take the
American public not settling unless they
get results it's not about the talking
it's about getting things done at the UN
it was very much about I don't want to
just read a speech I want to get
something done and we owe that to the
American people if we're gonna be in
office and I think that we need to
remind everyone in Congress that we
don't care about what your soundbite is
we don't care about the great you know
pushback that you gave would you do to
get it done and that's the question we
should be asking so I have to ask you to
tell the story of the famous picture of
you holding your hands up in the middle
of the UN people have only seen the
picture they may not know the backstory
so what exactly happened to precede that
photo your talk about the veto yeah you
know the veto vote I mean look it was it
was
really offensive to me that here you had
the international community and the
Security Council telling us that we
didn't have the right to move our
embassy to the capital of the country
where we put all of our embassies around
the world we always put them in the
capital so to move the embassy from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem was just stating a
fact Jerusalem is the capital of Israel
we were doing what we've done in every
other country and we were very honest
about it and for them to go and tell a
sovereign country what they can and
can't do I had my backup I was I was
angry and I think but that was the
proudest moment I had doing that veto
was telling the world you can try this
all you want but we are the United
States we're gonna continue to do what
we want to do how we want to do it and
this is right to us and so it was an
adamant vote I think is what people saw
in that picture I was just very I wanted
to make sure that they knew how strongly
I felt about it and how strongly the
American people felt about it so in a
second I don't know your daughter but I
do know your son nail and I'm gonna ask
you to humiliate him by giving
child-rearing tips in just a second if
you want to hear Nikki Haley's answer
about how to raise your kids you have to
be a daily wire subscriber to subscribe
to go to daily wire comm click Subscribe
you can hear the end of our conversation
there ambassador Haley thank you so much
for your time it's great to see you and
finally well I'm in the room with my
spirit animal guys so you can see we're
not in fact two sides of the same coin
so I really appreciate thanks so much
great to see you
[Music]
avenge Shakira shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Hiromi no
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Hulu the
Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]